I think it is
devastating to the image
of this city and especially
to our police department.
JOHN MACK: It's very
apparent that some--
not all, but some--
of those officers
are clearly out of control.
And they have to ultimately
be willing to take
a good, hard look at the
leadership of the department.
CROWD: [inaudible] gotta go!
[inaudible] gotta go!
ZEV YAROSLAVSKY: Mr.
President, all of us, I think,
have been stunned by
what has happened.
And I can't imagine that
the chief or anybody else
in the city would
condone the kind
of conversation that
took place-- both
electronically and by voice--
in that Foothill
division that night.
Blacks are not animals.
They're not lizards.
They're not apes.
They're not gorillas
anymore than any of us are.
They're human beings.
The first way to open
the door to brutalizing
people in any
place is to cheapen
their worth as human beings.
And when I read the transcripts
of the conversation,
I was appalled.
But the ability to freely
converse in racist terminology
suggests a level of tolerance
for that kind of discussion
that--
that is unacceptable by
any standard of decency.
Well, first of all,
this is a department
that this council has
supported over and over again.
This is a police department
that has supported you--
each of you.
And I just tell you this--
if you don't speak out on behalf
of the men and women of the Los
Angeles Police Department
that has served
the people of this city well--
if you don't do that at this
crucial moment in our history,
then I'm gonna tell you you're
gonna have a police department
that is not going to be
the kind of department
that you want, the kind of
department the people deserve.
JUDGE: Mr. Woo.
MICHAEL WOO: Thank you.
I want to know-- did you
mean that as a threat?
In other words, that if--
if I or other members
of the council
are going to be criticizing
you or the department,
are you saying that
you will withhold
support of these services to
fight crime in our districts?
That is the most
insulting thing
I have heard on
this council floor
in all the time I've been
here, and I've been here a lot
longer than you've been alive.
Absolutely not.
This is a professional
organization.
What do you think we are?
[inaudible]